the Joe Rogan experience where the
Vatican is there's like this courtyard
they have a an Egyptian obelisk that
somehow another they moved from Egypt I
mean this thing's huge
this huge stone obelisk that's carved
and and somehow another they got it and
had it stand up it's it's planted in the
middle of this little in the one in
Central Park zero Egyptian one from
Egypt huge from Egypt yeah whoa no [ __ ]
yeah what when was that one put in 1881
dude Central Park is pretty [ __ ]
amazing
if you're so lucky you can get an
apartment that overlooks Central Park
that makes New York a totally different
place Wow look at that man that's nuts
an Egyptian obelisk put in the New York
in New York in 1881 what yeah
that's nuts there's all sorts of
hieroglyphs all over Wow nobody tagged
it I know I've haven't you know I've
only seen it once the first time I'll
have 24-hour guards around the thing
I'll think so but they have guards all
over New York so someone might find it
quickly does cameras and stuff
honey maze that no one did anything to
[ __ ] with that that seems like a little
too precious to be just out in the rain
and snow I mean when when was that
constructed is that like an artifact
I've looked up the side don't remember
I've looked it up before it was like
transported there for a very particular
reason but there's like there's these
little crab calls at the very bottom of
it which you're like interesting hmm
well the whole thing's cool yeah yeah I
mean all of the hieroglyphs on it to it
that might be one of those things where
you could never put that there today if
you said hey there's a place in Egypt I
know we can get an obelisk this just put
in the middle Central Park they'd be
like get the [ __ ] out of here
Cleopatra's Needle yeah it's
unbelievable yeah people would be like
what what the [ __ ] are you talking about
man look I know you can't take an
Egyptian artifact and just leave it in a
park you take a 200 ton thing like that
on a boat strap
do you dick 200-ton granite obelisk
first shifted from vertical to
horizontal nearly crashing to the ground
the process steamship oh my god they
brought 200 tons and you're making the
[ __ ] ship left the 50 ton pedestal oh
you'd be looking at everybody on that
boat oh don't you eat too much you [ __ ]
we're barely hanging in here yeah 32
horses brought it from the banks of the
East River into the century into Central
Park it's already two horses with
railroad ramp they could imagine that
day god that's nuts
took 112 days to move the obelisk from a
quarantine station to its resting place
Wow yeah that's weird it's weird they
would just keep it there because again
like if you had a novelist that you
found those an ancient historical object
and you're like let's just leave it in
the park put in the middle the park it's
good if you can't do that you [ __ ]
all you have to put a fence around it
you have to put put it into glass this
is this is art that was made thousands
of years here these people are dead we
don't even know what they were doing
it's just sitting there
[Applause]